hello and welcome to this video playing
with freedom from the Netherlands I I
changed something in the layout I got
rid of this blitz chess number something
the thing is I have to update the number
before every recording and I know that I
think I already secured it up with one
of the earlier videos so this is off so
I just got rid of that I know that I'm
never going to be able to reliably
update this before every recording so
I'm just scrapping the number ok we
treat them he plays it like like yeah we
go into a Catalan so what I'm trying to
say and this is not exactly comfortable
fun can go fish of F over here mmm it's
all good yeah it's all good you can also
go Quincy to is also interesting but
this is almost certainly some kind of
transposition ok let's do this and see
if I can provoke 95
I cannot replace c5
one thing I just recognized if I if it
takes with the night which it does and
Knight c3 he has b5 witches ok I have
clean before that's not that terrible
but it's not not gray drill him I didn't
play that well this is a this is a
pretty bad move water for black hair and
I don't didn't exploit it I think I
should go be 50 of course now I have to
go Queen deform and he does not take it
should be seven and black is somewhat
okay of course a stupid shed stupid
chess I maybe had before him okay I can
take it
hmm yeah it's got Queen to be 7 11 of
the ideas and I'm actually slightly
worse yeah that's kind of embarrassing
before the really annoying idea can I
have no square for this night ah ok so
before maybe and I'm also suffering out
to be formed and probably after I mean
oh yeah yeah yeah
I go to three and not come on I probably
don't have much else night a for I was
thinking night a 4 here is going back
okay
before was hanging at the end he has the
better porn structure so sir this is the
thing but I might be able to if I do
this if I do this I see doing here I
hope the age probably Queen takes Queen
textbook textbook see one this is
actually not bad as rook c6 is kind of
awkward g5 okay
look the sixth I go rook c8 and Bishop
c5 he's suffering a little bit and is
ending all of a sudden
this is more annoying than rooks e6
first of all asking where this Bishop
should go doesn't have a very very
obvious square yeah and now okay sexy
sexy of course so take it chief and no
it should be to what am I doing here oh
my god this is terrible ah I came let's
go back
so a four is
I did it get it to hear right that it to
be six chap time morning okay he can
actually put it to c7 check on b2 is
annoying Luke c7 a bishop c7 I have rook
I wrote under seven I have okay I
wondered what a more active Rukia
no time here absolutely no time check
doesn't do much okay yeah yeah I know
it's a if this 15 seconds check check
check check check check game yeah bad
plane I just didn't play well there
should win this ending of course chair
and I've completely displayed the
opening really yeah this is not a
particularly good captain link for black
because he has committed himself soon I
be7 instead of going be fat but should
be seven so there should be some way to
exploit that maybe the engine gives this
I can switch that on of course that
might make sense there to make you be
595 possible and if he hasn't doesn't
have b5 if he has to go something like
this and this should be quite a torture
yeah a much better position than in the
game yeah this is and even here I
probably should go for in situ this is
this is just bad right my piece set up
is just bad Jim we see that I'm worse
and worse than this position yeah rookie
823 and he went back here that seems to
be correct i was thinking that a force
more more dangerous I was thinking cap
yeah yeah I thought this is annoying the
engine just does that Wow mm I know
I mean the computer can can can be
trusted here this is such an open
position where it is probably correct in
saying thats might be equal it i don't
think i would have played it that seems
unlikely yes so here that's not that
much going on and here i mean we should
have six is better okay I'm kind of
interested in in this this is getting a
little bit a little bit annoying for him
rookie 6 according to the engine okay I
was thinking that shake is good and no
here 28 okay this yeah okay and this is
just equal okay okay okay hmm yeah now
this is just a book a 5 is also good
this is just very stupid okay i still
think i had wind is somehow a track okay
look we won stronger I think in this
this this should be a win it really
should be a win technically this has to
go to go back
it doesn't have much isn't that many
squares in it could be a real issue and
no haha nerd I'm invading the problem in
the game was I mean have no time I was
kind of happy to trade the pawns just to
make sure that i'm not losing still on
time but normally I don't want to trade
the pawns of course I want to keep pawns
on the board especially there was those
weak bones okay anyway I hope you enjoy
the game thanks for watching